Adriana Garcia opened her natural
cosmetic shop four months ago in Caracas
betting on Venezuela's moderate economic
recovery and despite many hurdles she
says things have gone well so far
it's an economy in revision that's just
starting to grow again there is a
feeling of normality for Commerce and
many shopping centers have started
operating again
the government's decision to relax price
controls and allow trading in US Dollars
has given some businesses and president
Nicolas Maduro a second wind in a
country where Real gross domestic
product has shrunk by almost 80 percent
in a decade dollars are everywhere these
days prices in stores restaurants and
even food carts are listed in dollars
this has partly stabilized prices and
brought a veneer of better Economic
Times
together with more favorable
International geopolitics this has
allowed Maduro to venture outside the
country shaking hands with leaders who
were trying to house them until a few
months ago and confounding opponents
United States and other democracies
recognized as legitimate president after
calling maduro's 2018 re-election sham
spends most of his days in a Spartan
office photos on the wall show him at
the height of his efforts to topple
Maduro and although opposition parties
are now seeking to end this mandate he
remains on the third
we need to bring this to a presidential
election and we need to strengthen the
opposition to facilitate talks in Mexico
but let me be clear it's not because the
opposition is divided that Maduro keeps
the power he keeps usurping power
because this is a dictatorship maduro's
regime has agreed in theory to resume
negotiations with the opposition in
Mexico and arrange free and fair
presidential elections in 2024 in
exchange for ease U.S sanctions and the
oil sector
Maduro is hoping the economy will
continue improving enough to give him a
chance to win the next presidential
elections outright especially if the
opposition remains as divided as it is
right now but economists say the
improvements have done little for the
majority of Venezuelans
trying to credit himself for the
increase in economic activity but all
they've done is stop causing
hyperinflation still if things stand it
will create some peace among the middle
and upper class but this doesn't mean
better conditions for those who go to
public hospital or need Public Services
but for now avoiding hyperinflation
might be enough to offer some
opportunities to businesses like
Adriana's and the government more time
to maneuver Alessandra and pieti Al
Jazeera Caracas